Hello again, this is Session 2 of a new look at cancer.
This is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
And we got a lot to go over.
So again, I'm going to try to go fast to keep the short and keep your attention.
So stick with me.
Last week, we talked about that we are losing the war on cancer.
And since we started the war on cancer, we moved from 1 in 20 Americans,
having cancer to 1 in almost 2 Americans have cancer.
So this is a huge war that we are losing horribly.
We would have surrendered a long time ago if this truly was a war.
How does cancer progress?
So the difference between benign and malignant as far as tumors go is a benign tumor is slow growing.
It's not in a rapid replication phase.
That's really the biggest part.
A benign tumor is typically encapsulated.
It's not going anywhere.
Typical benign tumor would be a lipoma.
That would be a common benign tumor, very common benign tumor.
It could be removed surgically.
It's not going to metastasize.
It's never going to become cancer.
So malignant cancer is rapidly replicated.
It has the ability to metastasize because it's breaking off circulating tumor cells.
Why?
Because it's not encapsulated.
The cells have the ability to grow into a tumor themselves, somewhere else in the body.
It's poorly differentiated.
And it is something that you really need to treat.
But I, tumor, something you don't really need to treat.
How does cancer progress?
Well, there's a loss of normal growth control.
So normally, on top of the screen, it says there's normal cell division.
Normally, a liver cell reproduces itself about every six to 12 weeks.
The mother cell will typically then die.
It might go through two cycles of reproduction, and then eventually it will die.
You don't end up, if it continued to live, you'd end up with a fairly large liver by the end of your life.
So the mother cell always ends up dying.
And that death of that cell is called normal programmed cell death.
Or a name that we call apoptosis.
Cell suicide or apoptosis is the typical name.
So in a cancer cell, the cancer cell, what makes a cancer cell, a cancer cell?
It starts as a liver cell and it doesn't die.
It doesn't die because of some reason.
So there's a reason why it's not dying.
So understand the process of normal programmed cell death is very complicated.
It has to do with the receptors on the outside of the cell membrane,
in a long chemical process within the cell that causes the nucleus to implode.
Now, there can be a breakage.
There can be an impediment at the receptor site.
There can be a breakage somewhere in the apoptotic cycle
within the cell cytoplasm or within the nucleus itself.
But it'll always end up with apoptosis not taking place.
Even though apoptosis doesn't take place, that doesn't mean it's cancer.
So the second thing that has to happen with everybody that has a diagnosis of cancer
is that the replication cycle has to be broken so that it gets stuck in a rapid replication phase.
That by definition is cancer.
A apoptosis not taking place in an rapid replication phase.
Now, your immune system in a perfect world would attack a cancer cell.
And this happens on a daily basis.
So you've heard it say that everybody has cancer.
Is that true?
Yes, it is.
But not everybody's going to get a diagnosis of cancer.
Well, it's certainly a higher percentage of people than it was 25-30 years ago.
But not everybody will get a diagnosis of cancer.
Why?
Because normally your immune system should be able to kill the cancer cell.
So if a cell, a liver cell, doesn't go through apoptosis, so it's still alive,
it goes into a rapid replication phase.
By the time it gets into 10-20-100 cells large,
your immune system should recognize it as an enemy.
So, circulating TH1 cytokines and chemokines,
macrophages, and white blood cells,
should be the first to recognize it and go,
what in the world is that?
Let's kill it.
And your immune system destroys that cell, that growing cell mass,
and you never get a diagnosis of cancer.
That's in a perfect world.
So if you do have a diagnosis of cancer, at some point in time,
that did not happen.
And then even if your immune system is sparked up,
now you've got a diagnosis of cancer.
Now you're going to get a whole bunch of immune stimulants.
Why is it going away?
Because it's set to a larger size,
you need other further help.
Your immune system isn't strong enough to kill it.
We'll talk about some complications there.
So normally you lodge what's called a TH1 response.
That's on the top of this slide.
And then you lodge a TH2 response.
A TH1 response are mainly your killer cells.
Think of your TH1 side as your machine gun marine core.
That is out looking for an enemy.
And they see this growing cancer mass as an enemy.
This is a forwarded shooter.
What in the world is this?
This is a normal, let's kill it.
If it can't kill it, then it fires a TH2 response
that which typically makes antibodies,
and your TH2 response is making antibodies against this cancer mass.
So normally this should take place.
And if it catches it, in time your immune system has the ability to kill it
and you never get a diagnosis of cancer.
Now the problem comes in is that what if you have a suppressed immune system
for a period of time?
You're under a lot of stress.
You're taking medication that suppresses your immune system.
You have a chronic illness.
There's just a lot of things that could cause a suppression of your immune response.
And that can allow cancer that normally is being killed off
because you're producing it on a regular basis.
That's not getting killed off.
And that's how cancer can start.
So many, many times a patient will go, yeah,
I got diagnosed with the cancer in 2013 and in 2011.
I went through this huge stressful time where I lost my job for three months.
I didn't think how we were going to make it.
We lost our house and I finally got hired again.
Was that big, was that a big enough incident that could have set up
an immune suppression that allowed the cancer to grow the answers?
Yes, it is.
So that's what you want to look at how cancer progresses.
Now there's a lot of things to do when you look at this.
We want to stimulate an immune response.
So what are my favorites that we're going to talk about in a later session
is medicinal mushrooms.
Stimulating your immune response with herbs.
And just eating good food is a great way to make changes in your body.
So if you're under a lot of stress and you don't have a diagnosis of cancer,
eating good is really, really important.
Getting proper sleep is really, really important because that's what's going to block
these cancer cells from taking it off and really having a foothold in your body.
So in order for cancer to occur, your ugo genes,
the ability for the cancer to take off has to be turned on
and the tumor suppressor genes have to be basically suppressed.
So that's what we're going to get into next week.
So stay tuned.
We've got a lot to cover.
I'll see you next week.